let's build our intuition for visually
adding and subtracting vectors so let's
say that i have vector a
and i add that to vector b
to vector b and the resulting vector is
vector c
is vector c
so what could this look like visually if
we assume that a b and c are two
dimensional vectors
well i'm just going to draw what vector
a might look like so let's say that this
right over here is vector a
and vector b
vector b
since i'm adding it to vector a i'm
going to put its initial point
at
the terminal point of vector a and then
i'm going to draw vector b so let's say
vector b
looks like that
so that is vector b so let me label
these that is vector a
this is vector b
and i did that so that i could figure
out what the sum is what vector c is
going to be so that is vector b and what
would that be
well we would start at the
initial point of a vector a
and then go to the terminal point of
vector b so
this right over there would be the sum
so that would be
vector c
right over there so the important
realization is if i add two vectors i
would put the tail of one at the head of
the other and now what's neat about this
if i'm adding the order doesn't matter i
could have done this the other way
around i could have started with vector
b i could have said
vector b
plus vector a
is equal to vector c
is equal to vector c and you could see
that visually it would be a slightly
different
visual diagram but you get to the same
place so if i start with vector b let's
say i start over here let's say that
that's in fact you don't have to start
at the origin but let's say that was the
origin so i could start with vector b
draw a vector b
just like that
and then add vector a to it so start
vector a at the terminal point of vector
b and then go
to and then just draw vector a so vector
a so once again a vector i can shift
them around as long as i'm not changing
the direction or their magnitude so
vector a looks like that
and notice
if you now go start at the initial point
of b and go to the terminal point of a
you still get vector c so that's why a
plus b and b plus a are going to give
you the same thing
now what if instead of saying a plus b i
i wanted to think about what a minus b
is going to be so let me write that down
vector a
minus vector b
and let's call that vector d
that is equal to vector d
so once again i could start with vector
a and here order matters
so
vector a looks something like this this
is hand drawn so it's not going to be
completely perfect so vector a just like
that and it's one way of thinking about
subtracting vector b is instead of
adding vector b the way we did here we
could add negative b so negative b would
have the same magnitude but just the
opposite direction
so that's vector a vector negative b
will still start it right over here but
we'll go in the opposite direction so
let's do that so negative b is going to
look like this
is going to look something like this
so that is negative b
notice same magnitude exactly opposite
direction we flipped it around 180
degrees and now the resulting vector is
going to be d so vector d
is going to look like
that
vector
d
so c is a plus b d is a minus b or you
could even call this a plus
a plus
negative
b
now with that out of the way let's let's
draw some diagrams and go the other way
see if we can go from the diagrams to
the actual equations
so let's start with let me draw an
interesting one
so let's say that this
well let's say that's vector a
vector
a
let's say that
i'll use green
let's say that that
is vector b
and i will now use magenta
and let's say
that this
is vector c
vector c
so i encourage you to pause the video
and see if you can write an equation
that that defines this relationship
well this is interesting because they're
all going in a circle right over here
you have you have you could start it
you could start at
let's say that you started at this is
your initial point you said okay a plus
b
well a if you're trying to figure out
what a plus b is going to be the
resulting vector would go would start
here and end here but vector c is going
in the opposite direction
but we could instead of thinking about
vector c like this we could think about
the the opposite of vector c which would
do
so instead of calling this c i could
flip this around by calling it this
negative c
so i could
flip flip this around
and
now
the same color
this would be equal to
negative
c
notice before i just had vector c here
and it started at this point and ended
at this point now i just flipped it
around it has the exact opposite
direction same magnitude now it is
negative c and this makes it easier for
us to construct an equation because
negative c starts at the tip at the
initial point at the of or the tail of
vector a and it goes to the head of
vector b or the terminal point of vector
b so we can now write an equation we
could say vector a
plus vector b
plus
vector b
is equal to
is equal to not c it's equal to the
negative of vector c so hopefully you
found that interesting